alright guys my review time you know the
rules one listen and then we're gonna
judge this M word comes from uh Dave
Portnoy he's the president of bar stool
again one listen you know the rule
scores one between one and ten we're
gonna rank it and go okay I mean it's
got a lot of crunch I would say it's
more of like a New England New England
people are much more comfortable saying
that word really you think there's a
slight discomfort there was a little
awkwardness with it level of racism
would you say level of racism is low I
think yeah more like a donde my daughter
yeah mediocre a mediocre like don't move
in my neighborhood but you know you
could play it's cheesy your cheese a
little cheesy like you could play on the
same AAU team is my son don't really
infiltrate the family okay okay let's
see wow I would say that one al you are
the final judge on that one but that
would have I would say about a six point
eight six point eight what would you
what would you go on six point eight and
it came in a little hot the execution I
give them some points for style style
points out points there you should style
point give it a nice like one point six
well
more races yes oh okay like that n-word
would carry a noose with it you know
it's not like a news in it might be like
uh you cut me off hey yeah yeah yeah
that's more like you are in my you're in
my late you cut me away and I don't know
anything else about you this is my lane
what are you doing here what are you
doing in my lane oh my barbecuing in the
[Music]
[Applause]
the elevated voice that's how I talk to
my puppy if you raise your voice
multiple octaves if you go into like
apologetic like girlfriend mode like
yeah yeah but apologize not like that's
like that's like when marks lying
Oh Marxist that's your voice what would
you rate that n-word right there was
cute and it has high cuteness factor
yeah I cuteness high cuteness it was
like crispy around the front end and hey
so I give that like a 7.1 you go we're
Aiken and words or n dicks in all
seriousness now you are the final judge
on these n words obviously this is not
our place to judge so go that one I
don't know it started hot smooth
delivery I gotta give that what a the
cancel culture came after a bar stool
owner and see the owner I think he's
still the owner CEO or something no the
CEO is a woman they got a nice little
smoke screen that was genius like you
get called sexist and then you just get
a woman to be your CEO and then she's
that shield sounds call her daddy's
leverage I thought what was it that
their women that are like the forefront
of this network they're like that
they're the big eyes that's why he was
offering deals in his apology who's like
I never would offer this deal to anybody
else yeah cuz I got two women right here
that I like the people for my network
my bad Dave
man a bad 2020 but so basically the
cancer culture came after I'm they
probably went through every single thing
bar stools ever put out and they're
trying to I mean that clearly looks like
a targeted hit
they're like editing the video see my
problem yes please go first of all well
it's not getting the serious part yet
this appears to be some kind of stand-up
comedy situation the way he's holding
the microphone the way he's holding the
mic stand you can't release open my
footage like that's not as good material
yes nothing good at the polished he
didn't understand like the genius thing
of taking a bite of pizza revolutionary
innovation and content which is and he
didn't wait till he got to stage and
delivered like a Kramer N word that's
that's a strong six point one I'll scale
so is the scale is the scales based on
how racist you really think the person
is or how well executed the M word is
both oh so it's like if I'm a sucess son
there's this bit some nine say like two
years ago you'd heard not about a white
lady in a grocery store being told to
put a mask on like what kind of an where
does that go that's like that's a he's
measly to point to that's it whether to
oh dude we need to show the video later
I think her name on Twitter is Tina
forty this is my like dream woman I mean
this is doctor dreams you know who she
is
I don't know my god we got to get this
up but we'll stay on this right now okay
um so yeah so they go through all his
stuff find everything he said they're
like hey let's cancel and let's get this
guy out of here I don't think barstools
fans really care i from when I watch it
I don't think that he's saying this in a
hateful way if anything I just think
he's a you know arrogant like sometimes
you think when you don't have any like
white friend or sorry up black friends
like you think that this word
less harmful than it is yeah and I don't
expect Dave to have any black friends
you know I'm sure he grew up in a place
is quite segregated maybe of New England
or something like that and and then you
don't know that it's that bad and you
hear it in like music and you hear by
people saying it all the time you're
okay well they're saying it all the time
and it doesn't say yeah and I think that
a lot of white people do that and I
think if maybe you're someone like us
that actually grows up with black people
you hear how upset they get when someone
not even them like a friend of theirs or
any black person has called VMware by a
white person you're like [ __ ] I could
never say that way and it's really easy
not to say the word like I've been on
podcast for [ __ ] hours a week every
single week for the last I don't know
six years of my life and you only drop
five there's only five anyway and it was
a Trinidad James song I respect you like
you've never even slipped yeah I respect
that a lot I don't do it but it's
something I just never never did that's
you know that being said I think we do
draw a distinction between like a
hateful person and someone who says that
in terms of like repeating someone else
does seem like he was repeating I'm not
about to put the indictment on hate on
him no I don't think he's a hateful guy
no I just think they he just doesn't
have any boyfriends and probably didn't
grow up with a lot of diversity and just
doesn't know I'm not giving him that
easy and you haven't yet so what
everybody knows you don't say like
that's you know never black friends to
know you don't say it and the only
reason why he felt comfortable to say it
in that room because it was no woman no
black the room so it's like also
probably was doing something wrong and
he probably just didn't think he thought
that was like just for the show probably
won't live forever in the mic I did okay
go
I want I think I'd get away with this
yes I mean it's like I think but I think
a lot white people look at saying the
n-word no different than like making a
[ __ ] joke we're making a sexist joke
that loud why people have no black
friends right just don't know any black
people right so I think they're like oh
this is taboo just as taboo is me making
a [ __ ] joke just as taboo as me making
a sexist joke the more lights it only
white people in your life you know what
I mean like boats to whites
if you
like they don't know anything about how
this word affects people outside of like
a history textbook right right
or what they see on worldstar something
like that and he knows he's never gonna
run into any black people well now
things are probably different but in the
initial stages of arsal I don't know if
there are any black people there so we
have one black guy there the [ __ ] yeah
he can handle him is that worried of
what his reactions gonna be and I think
they sponsored him to come here from
Africa yeah he checked all the boxes
with with that higher like let's just
get this one guy we got a black [ __ ]
we got woman see you they know what
they're doing so um so that I think is
the question that we got to look at when
we look at like how people say things
especially if they're like in the guise
of getting a rise or getting some
laughter yeah I didn't buy intent
exactly we always say don't that what is
the intent not the attention I don't
think the intention was hateful it maybe
is a learning moment and you know maybe
his reaction to it now is like yo that
was stupid I was something I would never
do now I think he even said that on the
thing yeah now what is your thing what
is your feeling on that the idea that
like his apology you mean yeah like
where he yeah he basically came out he
was like look these are just using that
in like he was based like yo these are
jokes that do do in the office around in
the or like they had racially
insensitive jokes in the beginning of
the office but none we're damn bomb was
dropped right like like to try to group
it with that it's like he's trying
there's one way to lose to him doing
like the Chris Rock and Wars versus
black people bit but the point is but he
stopped they stopped yeah for that and
he's getting in trouble for saying yes I
was like oh his back were my so my
assumption he's like is like a rich
white kid who just never had any
minority friends and now he's in this
world where he's forced to interact with
people who are from all walks of life
and they probably has realized later on
in life oh [ __ ] that word really affects
people I'm not gonna make that as a
taboo joke yeah it's just typical like
you know like spoiled white kid I would
just respect any white person more well
especially if they're not using it in a
hateful way but just be like yo my bad
at the time I knew it was wrong but I
was around people that I I knew they
mind like just own up for take fully
accountability and don't try to take
full accountability for it there's AI
you realize you [ __ ] up yeah yeah also
can't really speak up if you pay them
you know what I mean like if a white
person it's just a tough position if you
get if you're a white dude that's my
boss he's saying in a way that I know
wasn't hateful I'm a white dude he pays
me do I just risk my job back yo don't
use that word even if it's joking yeah
so everybody's trying to pay their bills
essentially yeah man yeah yeah that's
bad if you have yes yes people yes maybe
that same energy about the Nazis I mean
it not trying to be funny you know I
mean you know is it how people always
jump to [ __ ] like you do anything like
you don't become Superman in any moment
and they're like yeah that's what
happened with the Nazis like someone
doesn't recycle their [ __ ] you're like
oh you're just gonna let it happen yeah
what about the Nazis oh you're just
gonna let it go to the landfill get
incinerated huh how hilarious Christ yo
so are we done with the Portnoy
discussion anything else yeah you know
it's not that hard a night use award
like you said I feel like you should be
able to say as a rule you should be able
to say whatever you want and then then
where does the exception that proves the
rule keep going on that what do you like
everywhere they always say oh that's the
exception that proves the rule
I think say whatever you want the n-word
is the one is the one exception and
that's the exception that proves the
rule yeah we have exceptions in life
right like the December 25th is no more
an important day than any other day but
we decide it's Christmas and we decide
everybody doesn't work and we decide
that we hang out with our family it is a
myth that we all choose to believe in
right now I'm not saying the n-word
being a bad word is a myth but it is
something that we've kind of like
culturally all accepted and it's this
weird way of like atoning for like
horrible behavior does it make up for it
is it the 40 acres of mule absolutely
not
but it's this it's this way we're like
every race especially white people can
go look some fucked-up things have
happened to black people yeah the very
least that I can do is avoid this one
[ __ ] word yeah
and I think when you say it as a white
guy I don't know you explain to me how
you feel but my imagine the assumption
is like you can't even do that yeah
don't say one [ __ ] word a lot of
shitty things have happened
we barely asked for anything you know
yeah that's why when you that's why our
reaction is like really like that's why
I think that our reaction is
over-the-top yeah because it's like oh
you're really just you already got your
foot on our neck or knee and you're just
like digging it in yeah it's like you
don't have like you that is such an easy
thing for ya not it and then the people
always be like yeah but if we all treat
people equally we would all say the word
and it's like yeah it'd be nice if we
were all equal yeah ideally in an ideal
world and someone will cut this and like
snip it out but in an ideal world but
I'm imagine black people would love it
if we were so equal that that word meant
nothing yeah yeah yeah like that's the
ideal world is that there was so much
equity there was an equitable
relationship of all races where you
could save whatever you want to him you
could say whatever you wanted me I could
say whatever I want to you
unfortunately because there is this kind
of class and race dynamic that exists
some of these words [ __ ] sting extra
and it just the too much history tied up
with that particular word so it's like
you I don't think you'll ever if you're
non-white people but also not black go
just say it's [ __ ] sand crackers be
honest be honest what happens it when
the black guy came into GMC to get some
creatine and then ran out without paying
your mom's hey you need the creatine in
the first place look pretty goddamn
[Applause]